[Music]
holy crap man I thought you were kidding
we're better to play Dungeons and
Dragons than in your own dungeon what's
so funny huge hunk please fine you know
I'm a total nerd I mean I got one of
those that thing right over there and a
bunch of these hey I've got an idea
last season a game of thrones let's
watch it together guys night
are you kidding yes right who's gonna
sit on the iron stone
cone the cone the iron cone iron iron
throne you know that Joe Reyes it's good
man okay so Joe okay excuse me sure what
the it's throne you're making me
look like an idiot in there just shut up
do your job so uh Sophia's gonna
whip up some chocolate chip cookies
should be done any second that didn't
sound like Sophia oh we haven't geeked
out on infinity war we all right we
haven't actually um it was crazy which
death hit you the heart oh god damn it
what's wrong
you okay um yeah yeah well we don't
infinity war which death hit you the
hardest all right which which death and
infinity war hit me the hardest which
death and infinity war hit me the
hardest duh sure dude all this equipment
is why are you even here yes sorry
we're subterranean so it's hard for the
waves to travel through the walls
what is the stone ah this is this is
this is my friend Taryn hello
he lives in this hallway I do and I
don't feed Joe nerd knowledge through an
IFB that isn't working today
Taryn I said I don't do that why why Joe
white might do this why do any of this
cuz it's not enough to be a stud
the Nerds have taken over I mean back in
the 80s I just beat the crap out of
dorks like you but can't anymore
now guys like Terran are in charge but I
mean look at him he deserves it he's got
kind eyes
sexual dynamism I could never go up to
which is why he's the great what now you
get the earpiece to work I'm just gonna
head out now I think master he knows too
much no you're not gonna tell anybody
about this
you should stay Josh we were just about
to play pogs right you like Pakistan Joe
has the biggest slammer you guys are
coming back soon right Joe Taron cookies
stay there in a second honey
hm I hope she's making her
snickerdoodles no no no no it's really
dark in here is your little friend
staying for cookies
[Music]